[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala
brothers and sisters and dear friends
Elon Musk recently in an interview said
the following listen for yourself he's
using common basic logic rationality to
come to basic conclusions something that
the thieving o occupiers this
genocidal uh State couldn't even think
of themselves here is the interview for
you to hear for the for an ey makes
everyone blind now now that neck of the
woods they really believe in the whole
ey for ey thing
um but I me you really have if if you're
not going to just
outright commit genocide like against an
entire people which obviously would not
be acceptable to to really shouldn't be
acceptable to anyone um then you you're
going to leave basically a lot of people
alive who subsequently you know hate
Israel so really the question is like
how for for every Hamas member that you
kill how many did you create mhm and if
you create more than you kill you've not
succeeded that's the you know the real
situation there um and it's safe to say
that if you know
um if you know if you kill somebody's
child in
Gaza you you you've made at least a few
uh homas members you heard for himself
it's very common basic logic which is
what if you are going to go and
terrorize steal the lands of these
people these people who have lived there
for thousands of years with the Jews and
the Christians in peace if you come
there steal their land persecute them
bully them take away the kids lock them
up blow the kids blow them and their
families into pieces cut their electric
gas water what do you think any group of
people or Nation will do which the UN
has given them a right which is what
that they have a right to Armed
resistance this is something that the UN
official has said not myself so Alon
musk is saying the same thing now let's
go to certain individuals like us
generals and individuals who have served
in the Army top us generals have pointed
out that drone strikes make us less safe
rather than safer former head of joint
specialist operations Commander Stanley
M mistal has also pointed out that
careless use of drone strikes could
result in a suicide attack in Central
Park a report carried out in 2014 by
General John abiz reported that civilan
casualties from drone strikes can affect
whole communities and become a potent
recruiting tool for terrorist
organizations General General General
Mike General Michael Flynn stated to M
Hassan in 2015 when you drop a bomb from
a drone you're investing you're going to
cause more damage than good former C
counterterrorism officer Robert gr
grenia has admitted that drone strikes
creates more enemies than you are REM
removing from the
battlefield and drone operator drone
operators have reported themselves that
that this only fuels the feelings of
hatred that ignite terrorism and groups
like Isis a study of Bureau of
Investigation investigative journalism
found that drone stripes in Afghanistan
Pakistan Yemen and Somalia since 2004
may have killed up the, 1400 civilians
including more than 200 children the
point is what I want you guys to put
yourself in their shoes or anyone's
shoes for that matter imagine I come to
your house occupy your house cause you
to live in the toilet humiliate you
every morning cut your water electric
gas whatever it may be for that matter
Massacre your kids blow them into pieces
and persecute you day in day out and
this is not just happening in the G
strip this happening in the West Bank
where over 100 40 individuals 140
Palestinians have been killed so the
point is what use this logic vice versa
imagine Israel is in Gaza and the
Palestinians are doing the same thing to
the Israelis and the Jews and Zionist
for that matter imagine the same thing
being done vice versa what do you think
would happen what do you think the
Western media would say the point is the
following the more you are attacking and
indiscriminately in a densely populated
place where you've killed over 11,000
innocent people you filthy Zionist scums
you scums and I hope God brings your end
I hope a day comes where the
Palestinians the Jews and the Christians
live in peace under that one country
which is
Palestine you are causing more harm than
good and these are generals officials
whove worked in the Army who are telling
you you are going to cause more hamus
you're going to cause more people join
Hamas than vice versa because anyone for
that matter I'm a father if a group a
gang in London was to come and kill my
kids my whole life and existence will be
nothing but to eliminate those gang
members I will live breathe eat sleep
with my one mission is what that they
have massacred my innocent men my
children my kids I I have a 2-month-old
I have a 2-year-old I have a
six-year-old and you as fathers and
mothers will know that if you was to
dare to see a A for pricking their
finger how your heart trembles imagine
seeing this you are causing
more more hate and you are causing more
of the Palestinians to go and join Hamas
then vice versa until you end occupation
until you stop brutally massacring these
people
when will there be ever an end to Hamas
when how do you even expect that and
that is what Elon Musk is pointing out
very
clearly and this is what's going to
happen it's going to cause more war and
more innocent people dying on both
sides leave the lands that you stole
leave the lands why don't the Americans
The Who support you so much give you
Florida why do you go to Florida
let's see how the American Red U you
know Bible uh uh um followers yes let's
see how the Americans would do if you
went to Florida and took over Florida
and did exactly the things there they
will be up in
arms and the point is what we do not
want any innocent Jew Christian Muslim
Hindu sik wherever for that matter to be
hurt and we do not want the killing and
killing the indiscriminate killing of
our Palestinian brothers and sisters may
Allah to elevate them and accept them as
Martyrs their PL you can see those
people have more faith there are people
coming to Islam and looking into Islam
just by looking how strong in faith
these people are you are never ever
going to defeat the Palestinians you
will never ever defeat the Muslims we
will voice our opinion and we will use
our social media and every platform that
we have to show the genocide that you
carrying out in
Gaza
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be AAR for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you will in
be reaping the reward click the link and
donate what you can